thank you to the organizers for inviting
me
for this talk today i will be talking to
you about
oncogene additivity in the pi3 kinase
pathway in cancer
my name is neil vassen and i am an
attending physician
at memorial sloan kettering cancer
center i am
a physician scientist and a breast
oncologist working on cell signaling
in breast cancer
these are my disclosures
oncogene activation is a hallmark of
cancer
and there are multiple ways that
oncogenes can be activated
proto-oncogenes that is oncogenes
that are not activated can be modified
in primarily three different ways gene
amplification
point mutation or translocation
and the identification of these
mechanisms and the resultant
oncoproteins that is the proteins coded
by these genes
has led to some of our blockbuster
targeted therapies
in cancer today
now pi3 kinase is an oncoprotein
complex composed of two proteins it has
a storied history
first discovered in the 1980s as a
factor bound to
polyoma middle tea viral protein
and later found to be a protein
that phosphorylates or places a
phosphate group
on the three position of
phosphoenocetide which is a
lipid species now at the time this was
quite novel because kinases up until
then
had been reported to phosphorylate
proteins and this was a lipid
kinase phosphorylating lipids later it
was found
that the pi3 kinase gene product or one
of the p aqua kinase gene products was
similar
to a product found in a retroviral
oncogene
derived from birds called asc-16
going into more detail pi3-kinase is a
heterodimeric
lipid kinase it's composed of two
different proteins that come together
and has enzymatic activity
the genes that code for the pi3 kinase
complex are two genes pic3ca
and pic3r1 pic3ca colored in blue
excuse me in gray codes for the protein
p110 alpha
while pic3r1 colored in green
codes for the protein p85 alpha p110
alpha is the catalytic subunit it's the
business end of the molecule if you will
while p85 alpha is the regulatory
subunit it's necessary for
p110 activity but in and of itself is
not
catalytic and together these proteins
bind together and form the pi3 kinase
alpha complex
the pi3 kinase alpha complex as shown in
the figure
outlined in red sits at the hub
connecting
in the cell connecting extracellular
signaling mostly through receptor
tyrosine kinases
intracellular signaling as shown in the
diagram
pi3 kinase catalyzes the formation
of pip 3 which is a lipid species with
three
different phosphorylations from the
lipid species pip2
now pip3 is a potent second messenger
molecule that sits at the cell membrane
and recruits a variety of proteins to
the cell membrane most notably akt
akt is a protein kinase that leads to
the phosphorylation of many downstream
substrates
that are important and necessary for a
variety of cellular functions including
protein synthesis
metabolism such as glycolysis and cell
survival
what makes pi3 kinase signaling rather
complicated is that there are a number
of
genes coding for different catalytic
subunits
different regulatory subunits and also
there is a cell specificity with
many of these proteins there are four
different isoforms of pic3ca
alpha beta gamma and delta there are
also multiple isoforms and splice
variants of pic3
r1 the majority of which are poorly
understood
adding to the complexity the alpha and
beta pi3 kinase complexes
are expressed in all cell types while
gamma and delta are primarily restricted
to
immune cells delta in lymphocytes
primarily and gamma and myelocytes
primarily
and together these different isoforms
splice variants
and cell types help diversify cell
signaling through the pi3 kinase pathway
now pi3 kinase in the oncology space
was elucidated in the 2000s by multiple
papers
many from the group at johns hopkins
hopkins
and these groups found in 2004
that single pik3ca mutations are
frequent events in human cancer
that they're sufficient for cell growth
and can also be inhibited by small
molecules
and much of this work culminated in a
crystal structure of a truncated pi3
kinase complex in 2007
and this has spurred tremendous drug
development efforts in this field
pic3ca is actually the most frequently
mutated oncogene
in human cancer that is a gene whose
mutated products
causes cancer and on the right hand side
this
is a histogram showing various cancer
types
and their frequencies of pic3ca
alterations
mutations shown in green and other
alterations shown
and i would like to draw your attention
to breast cancer
where pic3ca mutations are found in
about 40 percent
of estrogen receptor or er positive
breast tumors so these are tumors that
overexpress the estrogen receptor
now what makes these mutations rather
complicated to study is that there are a
lot of them
they're located all throughout the gene
and they have varying levels of activity
shown in the pie chart you can see that
the most frequent so-called hotspot
mutations that is mutations that are
very frequent are found at
e542k e545k
and h1047r these are the mutation
positions that means that the other
mutation
uh the other mutation part of this pie
chart is actually the majority of
mutations about 60
and as you can see in the lollipop plot
in the second panel
these mutations are scattered throughout
the gene in all different domains
this is important because this is one
way that
lipid kinases like pi3 kinases differ
from protein kinases where
often in protein kinases such as
receptor tyrosine kinases
mutations are primarily in one domain
the kinase domain
and this makes it complicated to study
these pi3 kinase mutations because it
necessitates looking at the entire
protein complex
not just one domain in isolation
almost all of these mutations are what
we call allosteric
they're not located in the enzyme
excuse me in the in the kinase domain
where the atp
molecule which is the molecule whose
phosphate group is transferred to new
lipid species
is located and this again makes these
mutations rather complicated to study
finally as shown in the graph on the
bottom we have
some data on activation the activation
capacity of these
different mutations as measured by cell
growth in a variety of non-transformed
or non-cancer cell lines
but we have very little data on drug
sensitivity that is do these mutations
actually predict for
drug sensitivity or drug resistance
apart from the most frequent hot spots
that are shown in red
i think it's very important to note that
we have had many drugs
that have targeted this pathway over the
decades
starting in first discovered in the 50s
and really
explored in the later decades where
so-called pikk
inhibitors these are inhibitors that hit
pi3 kinase but also
other large pi three kinase related
kinases such as mtor
atm and atr and then led to
more specificity these inhibitors called
dual pip kinase m2 inhibitors
and then finally pan pi3 kinase
inhibitors inhibitors that inhibit all
the different
isoforms that i mentioned earlier of pi3
kinase
now unfortunately none of these drugs
advanced in the drug discovery process
due to either less efficacy
less than predicted efficacy or mild
efficacy at the expense of high toxicity
i should note that many other nodes of
the pi3 kinase pathway such as
mtor has been successfully inhibited and
have led to fda approved drugs in a
variety of cancer types such as
everolimus and tensor alignments which
are fda approved in breast cancer
kidney cancer and pancreatic
neuroendocrine tumors additionally we
have other pi3 kinase isoforms that can
be inhibited such as psp kinase delta
shown on the right hand side and this
has led to fda approval of a number of
drugs in lymphoma
but pi3 kinase alpha which is the
primary driver of breast cancer
inhibitors for these molecular kinase
alpha
were recently developed and have led to
an fda approval of the drug called
alpelism and breast cancer that i'll
explain in the next slide
and finally i put at the bottom a pi3
kinase or picked we see a mutant
selective inhibitor
many of the toxicities of this drug
class are due to
on target inhibition of insulin
signaling and so
if we could have a drug that inhibited
mutants
pic3ca as would be found in cancer
but not wildcite pic3ca this would be a
huge step forward for the field
here is shown a
graph of multiple phase three trials
randomized clinical trials that have
actually shown a benefit for pi3 kinase
inhibitors in pic3ca mutant estrogen
receptor positive breast cancer
and what is rather stymieing
is that all of these clinical trials
were positive clinical trials they met
their primary endpoint
increasing either pathologic complete
response or progression-free survival
with combining a pi3 kinase inhibitor
with standard endocrine therapy
but because of these on-target toxicity
issues due to inhibition of the insulin
signaling pathway
none of these drugs move forward in the
drug discovery process with the
exception of alkalism shown in the red
box
and this is the clinical trial that led
to fda approval of alpelism
this was the solar one trial which
tested the combination of sulvestrant
a selective estrogen receptor degrader
which is a standard therapy
in combination with alpelisiv a pip
kinase alpha specific inhibitor
in patients with pic3ca metastatic
estrogen receptor positive breast cancer
again pip3ca mutations are found in
about 40
of patients with er positive breast
cancer so this is a large patient
population
and this clinical trial met its primary
endpoint increasing progression free
survival from about 6 months to 11
months
now one important point borne out in
this trial as well as prior trials is
that
pi3 kinase and alpha inhibitors and
breast cancer at least are not
effective in picks we see a wild type
tumors
and there are other pi3 kinase alpha
specific inhibitors in clinical trials
notably gdc077
but this trial was the pivotal phase iii
trial that led to fda approval of this
combination in may of 2019.
when i started in the laboratory i was
interested in
if there are maybe other factors that
may cooperate with pix3ca mutations
to increase response to pi3 kinase
inhibition and this is shown
or this idea is shown in this in this
picture here where
you could imagine that with pic3ca
mutations that these tumors are
sensitive to pi3 kinase inhibitors are
shown in the gray dotted line
but could there be another genotype or
another factor that cooperates with
pic3c mutations to really drive
increased sensitivity to these drugs
and the germ for this study came
from the identification of an
exceptional responder patient to
alpelism
by maricio scaltrity's group in 2015
this paper identified a patient who had
a long response to
al pellissip monotherapy but then
developed acquired resistance and the
nature of this acquired resistance
was due to mutations in the cognate
enzyme p10
which antagonizes the effects of pi3
kinase
now when i started i was interested in
why this patient may have had such an
exceptional response in the first place
and it turned out that this patient was
a breast cancer patient
who had double pic3ca mutations in her
primary tumor
as well as 14 out of 14 metastases
this graph here shows the variant allele
frequency or the percentage of
alleles that contain the mutant the
mutation of
the mutation that's indicated and these
varying allele frequencies or vas are
graphed
one mutation versus the second and you
can see about a one-to-one correlation
here in
both the primary untreated tumor as well
as all the metastases
now this correlation between double pca
mutations and an improved response was
also echoed
in a recent phase one clinical trial
shown in panel b that our group
published in nature cancer in this year
this was a trial that tested al pelosi
in combination with an aromatase
inhibitor another standard endocrine
therapy
in er positive breast cancer and what we
found
was two interesting findings the first
was that in a population
of 51 patients nine patients actually
contained
had tumors that contained double pic3ca
mutations and this was surprising
because this
phenomenon had not been reported and
this seemed like a high number
moreover these nine patients had an
improved progression-free survival of
almost a year
compared to patients with single picture
mutations about 20 weeks or 5
months now this was not statistically
significant due to small numbers but we
thought that this was an interesting
signal
we also thought that this signal of
improved response may be due to the pi3
kinase inhibitor rather than endocrine
therapy
alone keep in mind please that all
patients
almost all patients receiving these
drugs received the combination therapy
we thought that this was due to pi3
kinase because as you can see in panel c
patients have similar responses to
endocrine therapy regardless of
their pic3ca mutational status whether
it's wild types shown in gray
single mutants shown in green or
multiple mutants shown in red
in response to multiple types of
endocrine therapy aromatase inhibitors
at the top
and selective estrogen receptor
degraders like fulvestrine at the bottom
so armed with this data we asked a very
simple question
what is the frequency of double pca
mutations in breast cancer
and what we were shocked to find was
that multiple pca mutations are found
in about 10 to 15 percent of all p3ca
mutant cancers
this is a bar graph a series of bar
graphs
identifying patients in c bio portal
most of these patients have
uh most of these tumors are primary
tumors and as you can see
we see about a 10 to 15 percent rate of
multiple picture mutations in p3c and
mutant cancers
and this is true in both common cancers
like breast cancer and colorectal cancer
but marching down this graph you can see
that even in the rare cancer types which
are shown in the second insect
that we see this persistent signal and
we recapitulated these data
also in msk impact which is our internal
biorepository that is enriched in
metastatic patients
we found in all of our data sets that
the vast majority of multiple mutant
tumors
contain exactly excuse me two pick three
ca mutations
next we check to see if these mutations
are
scattered randomly throughout the gene
or if they're enriched at certain amino
acid positions and we performed
so-called codon enrichment analysis
asking the question
do mutations at a particular position
are they more frequent in
single mutant tumors versus multiple
mutant tumors and as you can see
in the pink circles in the left hand
figure in breast cancer
mutations at positions 726 453 and 1043
are found primarily in multiple mutant
tumors compared to single mutant tumors
you can see the common hot spot
mutations 5 4 2 5 4 545 and 1047
are found just as frequently in single
mutant tumors
shown in gray as in multiple immune
tumors and what's interesting is that
this
mutational pattern is different in other
cancers shown in the blue circles
uh most of these data here are
colorectal and endometrial cancers
where mutations in 88 and 93
in the n-terminus of pic3ca are more
frequent
in multiple mutant tumors and again we
recapitulated these data in msk impact
in a complementary data set and so
putting these data together
showed in the box these are the most
frequent double pickpca mutation
combinations that we observe in breast
cancer
a combination of what we term a major
mutation 542 545 or ten four seven
combined with a second site mutation
rarely found alone in breast cancer 453
726 and 10 43 and we'll come back to
these
specific combinations a little bit later
now we next wanted to find out are these
mutations actually in the same cell in
the cancer and to do this we performed a
clonality analysis using
facets a computational algorithm and
using this algorithm we found that both
mutations are clonal
that is both mutations are in the same
cell
we also performed additional clinical
analysis of
breast cancers bearing double pic2ca
mutations and we found
that echoing our initial data that
double picture mutations are just as
frequently found in primary untreated
tumors as they are in metastatic tumors
this is an important point showing that
multiple mutations are not simply the
manifestation of drug treatment or tumor
heterogeneity
and in the bottom bar graph you can see
that double mutations are enriched in
so-called hormone receptor positive or
estrogen receptor positive her2-negative
breast tumors
and are much rarer events in
her2-positive breast tumors or triple
negative breast tumors
next we wanted to discover the allelic
configuration
of double pickpca mutations this is
incredibly important because
any mutation any two mutations that is
can be
either on the same piece of dna or on
separate pieces of dna
if they were on separate pieces of dna
as shown in the middle
in green and red and yellow so-called
transmutations these would code for
single proteins with
different mutations but if the mutations
were in the same piece of dna as shown
in the red boxes
these pieces of dna would code for
single proteins with multiple mutations
now based on our clonality data we
hypothesized
that double pic3ca mutations are insists
on the same allele
but we were cyanide initially when we
tried to investigate this because there
is no general
method to phase mutations far apart in
the gene in a single read
and the this slide outlines two of the
technical hurdles that we had to
overcome to answer this question
the first is that most tumor samples are
preserved as ffpe
or formalin fixed paraffin embedded this
procedure
degrades dna into very small fragments
comprising about 200 base pairs
therefore any mutations that are further
apart in the gene than 200 base pairs
which it turns out all of the double
mutation combinations that we observed
are excuse me the most frequent double
mutation combinations that we observed
are
that it's impossible to phase these
mutations from archival samples
and therefore to overcome this hurdle we
obtain fresh tumor samples obtained on
an irb
on an institutional review board
approved protocol
secondly the vast majority of sequencing
techniques that we use
to determine the allele configuration of
mutations
uses ngs next generation sequencing or
sanger sequencing and these are short
distance sequencing reads
and we sought a technique that could
perform long-range sequencing
reads to phase these mutations in a
single piece of dna
in tumor samples and so to do this we
turn to a long-range sequencing
technique
and this is an outline of the technique
that we leveraged called smrt sequencing
or single molecule real-time sequencing
this is a very exciting tool that has
been developed over the past
decade by several groups
most notably the groups at pac bio who
have
uh who who make this uh who have
pioneered the sequencing technique
and what this technique leverages shown
in panel a
is a highly processive dna polymerase
molecule
which is the engine that sequences dna
and what this molecule when engineered
with high processivity is able to do
is to sequence circular pieces of dna
and keep whizzing round and round this
circular piece of dna
to spit out dna sequences that can be
processed and analyzed to form consensus
dna sequences with extremely high
fidelity this is a very important
technical point that this
sequences amplicons of circular dna
because the vast majority of dna that we
send for sequencing in the laboratory is
linear pieces of dna
and of course a dna polymerase molecule
can sequence that linear piece of dna
but then it will fall off
and what this sequencing technique
allows for is
multiple tens of thousands of reads of
circular pieces of dna
and this technique shown in panel b can
sequence up to 30 kilobases of dna and
extremely long length of dna
in a single reed and this is very
exciting technology because as shown in
the previous slide every single one of
our double mutant combinations
was very far apart in the gene and so we
thought this could be a technique that
could actually help us
figure out if these mutations are in the
same allele or not
now working with our friends
at mount sinai school of medicine and
bobby sebra
we devised a protocol where we initially
identified metastatic patients
who had double pixel mutations using a
next generation sequencing platform
msk impact we consented them to our
biospecimen protocol
and these patients graciously underwent
fresh metastatic tissue biopsy
and we performed the workflow shown here
we first
optimized this workflow to determine the
allele configuration of
several parental cancer cell lines
that have multiple pic3ca mutations and
in data that i'm not showing you here
we determined that many of these cell
lines have
mutations that insist on the same allele
and some of them actually have mutations
in trans
but we were able to use this workflow to
optimize this technique after optimizing
this technique
we turned to our patient samples
to determine the allele configuration of
the double mutations
and this is actually our data
of each of six patients bearing
six different double pca mutation
combinations and the bottom line is that
all of these mutations are in cysts on
the same allele
i'd like to walk you through a little
bit of this data in the first row
we have a patient with e545k e726k
this is the most frequent double
mutation combination that we see in
breast cancer
and looking at the colored bars on the
right you can see that 56.1 excuse me
58.1 percent of amplicons
contain mutations in cis on the same
allele which are shown in the red
squares
now 39.5 of the amplicons
have wild-type dna this is to be
expected because
breast or all tumor biopsies are not 100
pure so we're going to have some wild
type dna in there but only two percent
contain
amplicon contained e726k alone shown in
yellow
and only 0.2 in this sample contained e5
or 5k mutations in trans and if we march
down to these other patient samples you
can see that the vast majority of the
mutant amplicons are insists on the same
allele
we also used orthogonal techniques such
as colony sequencing
next generation sequencing and rna
sequencing to validate
rare double mutations that are actually
very close together in the gene
using these short read techniques
and to our knowledge this is the first
use of smrt sequencing
to phase multiple alterations in solid
tumors
and therefore all of these data together
show that at least in breast cancer the
vast majority of double pca mutations
are in cysts on the same allele
now armed with this data that these
mutations were insist
we proceeded to functionally
characterize the effects of double
mutation
we focused in panel a on the mutation
combination sewn in the second gray box
and in all of these functional assays we
tested
the wild type gene mutation a
mutation b and mutation a plus b
and so in panel b we assembled a series
of isogenic
cell lines these are cell lines uh that
only differ
in their pic we see a mutation and
otherwise are genetically similar
and we performed western blotting
looking at cell signaling pathways and
as you can see in the western blot
double mutations for as i'm showing here
double mutations have increased
signaling in the pi3 kinase pathway
both proximally at the level of fosso
akt
and distally at the level of phosphos6
what's pretty striking is that at the
level of fosso s6 you can see that
the western blotting that these bands
are
uh only present in the double mutants
and are really not present in the wild
type or the single mutant
and so therefore double mutations
increase pi3 kinase pathway signaling
compared to single mutations
we also have similar findings in
different cell lines here we tested
mcf10a cells these are breast
normal epithelial breast cells but we
also have similar findings using nih3t3
cells which are mouse fibroblasts
as well as mcf7 er positive breast
cancer cells
we looked at signaling kinetics that is
signaling over different time points and
we found that at a 48 hour time point
the double mutants have increased
signaling compared to the single mutants
and wild type as shown at the
in this series of western blots
we tested we next tested to see if this
increase in signaling correlates with an
increase in cell growth and we
we see that yes that this is true you
can see that the double mutants have
increased cell growth in panel a by
crystal violet staining
and this is quantified in panel b and
here we're starting to see
synergistic effects where the effects of
the double mutant are much greater than
the additive effects of each constituent
single mutant alone
we also tested if these mutations
expressed in
trans that is on separate alleles what
the effects of these are and we found
that
in trans these double mutations
have similar signaling levels to the
single mutant as shown in the left-hand
panel and do not have
increased cell signaling or using
increased cell growth in the right-hand
panel
compared to the mutations in cis
we looked at the effects of our
mutations in
mice in mouse models by creating
allograft
allograft that is taking our cell lines
and injecting them into mice and
monitoring for tumor growth
and as you can see the double mutant
shown in light blue e726k
h1047r this has increased this confers
increased tumor growth compared to
single mutants
and wild type in a mouse model and also
leads to increased cell signaling as
shown in western blotting in panel b
and by immunohistochemistry in panel c
next we wanted to investigate the
mechanism of how
the pi3 kinase complex is modified by
these double mutations
and so to do this i'd like to first take
a long a big step back
to investigate or to to discuss what's
known about how these two different
proteins
p110 and p85 function and work from
jonathan backers group
very elegant work has shown that p110
which is a catalytic subunit again coded
by pic3ca
is both stabilized and inhibited by p85
the regulatory subunit
and this is shown in panel a this is
pulse chase showing that
p110 by itself degrades
at about two hours while in the presence
of p85
this complex is stable for at least five
hours
and this increase in stability
correlates with a
decrease in activity as shown in panel b
and this is quantified in panel c where
p110 by itself has high catalytic
activity
in the dotted line when bound to p85
this catalytic activity is decreased
and is partially rescued with the
addition of a phosphopeptide
now the addition of a phosphopeptide is
a
mimic of what happens normally in a cell
where a receptor tyrosine kinase such as
the insulin receptor
is phosphorylated and then binds to pi
pi3 kinase
for downstream signaling and this
phosphopeptide binding also leads to
increased lipid binding
now this graph this is just a pictorial
representation of the data that i showed
you in the prior panel
uh that in the presence of p85 the wild
type pi3 kinase complex has low levels
of kinase activity
and that sequentially with the addition
of fossil peptide this opens up the
protein kinase complex
leading to increased lipid binding and
when p110
is by itself that is as a monomer
it has very high catalytic activity so
now amidst this framework
how do the single hotspot mutations
e545k and h1047r
function and this is a pictorial
representation of a number of
seminal beautiful biochemical and
biophysical experiments
done by many groups over the years and
what these groups have shown
uh notably mario ansel's group and roger
williams's group
is that e545k functions as what we term
a disruptor
it disrupts the inhibitory interactions
between p85 and p110
opening up the protein complex and
other mutations that are at the p110 p85
binding
interface have a similar mechanism of
action
in contrast h-1047-r which is located in
the c-terminus at the
at the end of the p-110 protein
functions as what we call a binder it
increases lipid membrane binding
and this is pictorially represented here
and other mutations that are in the
c-terminus of p-110
have a similar mechanism of action so
therefore
this has established the most frequent
hotspot mutation mechanism
and now what is the mechanism of these
other second
spot mutations that we identified
in panel a this is a domain schematic
showing the location
in green of the second site mutations
453
726 and 1043. in pedal b
this is the crystal structure with all
of these five uh three different
mutational positions
and five four five ten four seven shown
as black spheres
as you can see four five three e5453 is
located at the binding interface between
p110
in blue and p85 and orange it's right
between the orange and the blue
same thing with five sides uh
1043 is located very close to 1047
in the c-terminus of pic3ca
and 726 is located in this loop here
far away from these other mutation sites
therefore we speculated
that e453q functions as what we
determine disruptor just like e545k
and m1043l functions what we term
as what we term binder like h1047r
however e726k nothing was known about
what this mutation might be doing
but based on the crystal structure shown
in panel b as well as in this slide
showing the alignment of multiple
crystal structures
you can see that e726 is located in this
loop that is
right by the putative lipid membrane
plane
now e726 is an uh amino acid called
glutamic acid which is acidic
and is negatively charged if mutated to
a k which is a lysine residue lysine is
a positively charged amino acid
now this is important because lipid
membrane phospholipids are negatively
charged phospholipids
and so we would predict that if we have
a mutation to a positively charged amino
acid
this may increase affinity with a
negatively charged phospholipid
in a membrane therefore we speculated
that e726 would function as a binder
and together these classical papers in
the field combined with our
investigation of the crystal structure
vis-a-vis the mutations that we have
identified in our study led us to the
hypothesis that double mutants activate
pi3-kinase by both
increasing p85 disinhibition that is
increasing the disruption
as well as increasing membrane binding
now to investigate this hypothesis
we prepared recombinant full-length
human pi3 kinase mutant protein
complexes them
complexes and subjected them to a
variety of biochemical experiments
to investigate p85 disinhibition we
performed an assay called thermal shift
this is an assay that measures protein
destabilization
and we interpret that as a proxy for p85
disinhibition
this is the western blotting what we do
is we take our proteins and heat them on
a temperature gradient from 46 degrees
to 63 degrees
and the protein complexes are blotted by
western blotting
to look for the temperature at which the
protein denatures
you can see that wild type we see five
spots
at our on our temperature gradient but
only four spots with e545k
showing that e545k denatures at a lower
temperature than wild type and this is
the raw data
of our experiments and as you can see
the double mutants which is shown in the
lower
the lowest row in each panel the double
mutants
denature at a lower temperature than the
single mutants or wild type
this is quantified here in panel a where
you can see that the double mutants have
lower melting temperatures than the
single mutants or wild type
in panel b we performed lipid kinase
acids using radioactivity
directly measuring the product of the
kinase reaction and we can
we we showed that the double mutants
have increased lipid kinase activity
compared to the single mutant
and finally we looked at lipid binding
by preparing
liposomes that is circular vesicles of
lipids
with different lipid species and we
measured their binding with our
recombinant pi3 kinase protein complexes
and as you can see in penal c in the
western blocks which is quantified in
panel d
all the double mutants had increased
lipid binding compared to the single
mutants or wild type
therefore putting all of these data
together these
biochemical data suggests that double
pcc mutations increase kinase activity
through a disruptor binder combination
mechanism
next we wanted to investigate in our
cellular models
how double picture mutations may modify
sensitivity
to pi3 kinase inhibitors
we took our cell lines and exposed them
to our pellets
the western blocks i'm showing you here
are short-term one-hour drug treatments
and as you can see in the absence of
drug as shown in the minus
columns the double mutants have
increased picc kinase signaling compared
to single mutants
however in the presence of drug as shown
in the plus columns
the signaling is abrogated under all
conditions
and we showed similar findings in our
other cellular models
now this was a short-term drug treatment
for one hour however when we expose
these cells to much
longer durations of drug treatment in
this
experiment four days you can see that
the double mutants
are actually more sensitive to pi3
kinase inhibitors than single mutants
for clarity i've broken this up into the
double mutants containing e545k
in the top panel and the double mutants
containing h1047r
in the bottom panel in the top panel you
can see that
the double e 5 4 5 k e 7 26 k and e 5 4
5 k
m 10 43 l as shown in the purple and
brown
curves are more sensitive that is uh
their cells are killed with a lower
concentration of drug compared to e545k
and in turn e545k is more sensitive than
these rare single mutants found rarely
by themselves in rescue
and this is true at the bottom with the
h1047r containing double mutant
and these patterns of drug sensitivity
by western blotting
and by cell viability assays were
recapitulated
uh showing almost identical results
using a structurally dissimilar
pi3 kinase inhibitor gdc007 which is now
in late stage clinical trials
we also tested our transmutant cells and
showed that the transmutants are not in
fact more sensitive to alpella sub
versus single mutants
in this curve in these curves the
transmutant is shown in the light blue
dotted line and you can see that these
the drug sensitivity of the transmutant
is very similar to the single mutant
finally we wanted to validate our
hypothesis
connecting and correlating the increased
response
of double pictures in tumors to pisce
kinase inhibitors
in a clinical setting
and to do this we teamed up with
genentech
to perform a secondary analysis of the
sandpiper clinical trial
now this clinical trial was similar to
the solar one trial
regarding patient inclusion criteria it
had a very similar patient population
and this trial tested the addition of
tiscellosim
a pi3 kinase alpha inhibitor to
fulvestrine which is an er degrader
in pic3ca mutant metastatic estrogen
receptor positive breast cancer
this trial enrolled 631 patients and
339 patients had pic3ca mutations
of those 339 patients shown in gray 66
patients shown in blue
had multiple picture mutations while 273
patients shown in orange
had one pcc mutation i'd like to point
out that
for this analysis we used circulating
tumor dna
to determine pc3 mutational status and
we did this because
many patients with er positive breast
cancer
have bone only metastases and bone
biopsies are very difficult to analyze
due to the need for decalcification
and so therefore we use ct dna which we
rationalized would allow us to analyze a
larger number of patients
this is a so-called waterfall plot of
the patients on the tesla sub arm of the
sandpiper trial
each var represents a single patient and
positive y-axis shown in the left-hand
side
correlates with two corresponds with
tumor growth whereas
negative on negative y-axis corresponds
with
a tumor shrinkage now first ignoring the
colors we can see
that more patients had tumor shrinkage
than tumor growth this is consistent
with the fact that this was a positive
clinical trial again this drug did not
move forward in the drug discovery
process due to increased toxicity
and then looking at the colors we can
see that multiple mutant patients shown
in blue
have more of a increased tumor shrinkage
compared to single mutant patients shown
in orange
and this is quantified in this in these
bar graphs in panel a this is the total
mutant population or the total
uh population of patients with pixie
mutations
you can see an increased response rate
in with the addition of testosin
and this is the whole patient population
and when we break it up into patients
with
single pictures of mutant tumors versus
multiple pigments immune tumors
we see that the patients with single
picture tumors had an
increased response rate but this was not
statistically significant
while the patients with multiple picture
mutant tumors shown in blue
had an increased response rate which was
statistically significant
now i'd like to point out that of course
this was not the primary endpoint of
this
sandpiper clinical trial to investigate
double
the responsive double pca mutant
patients
but this reflects the best available
clinical data at this time to
ascertain and and elucidate our
hypothesis
and we await publication of the
sandpiper clinical trial
to determine the effective double pcn
mutations on
progression-free survival in this
population
and so together these data suggest what
we term a
mutational dosage model for pi3 kinase
activation and inhibition in breast
cancer
wild type pi3 kinase alpha as shown in
the third row
of this box leads to increased akt
signaling while mutant pi3 kinase leads
to even more increased akt signaling and
double
double mutant pi free kinase leads to
even more akt signaling and increased
cell growth and this is important
because it correlates
with a clinically meaningful phenotype
of increased response to pi3 kinase
alpha inhibitors
for double p acme chinese mutant tumors
and these data points to a
second mechanism for oncogene activation
of double pca mutations in cysts
and so in conclusion i've shown you that
double pca mutations are a novel and
frequent genomic alteration in pc and
mutant cancers
they're insist on the same allele
they activate pi3 kinase signaling and
growth more than single mutants
we've shown this in a variety of models
and they do this through a novel
combination
disruptor binder biochemical mechanism
we showed that cysteine increased
response to pi3 kinase alpha
inhibitors compared to single mutants in
breast cancer
and we believe that this is a rationale
to test pi3 kinase alpha inhibitors
in multiple pcc immune cancers
with this i would i would like to
acknowledge many people
jose baselga and mauricio scout for
providing an exceptional laboratory
environment to investigate this question
lou cantley's lab at wild cornell for
tremendous help with our biochemistry
experiments
my fellow breast oncologist on the
memorial sloan-kettering
cancer center breast medicine service
for helping me obtain patient samples
my many other collaborators at mskcc
bobby sebred melissa smith at mount
sinai genome sciences
they were uh tremendously helpful
and and critical for helping us with the
single molecule real time sequencing or
smrt seek
my other collaborators well rabadon more
and more dickler
lori friedman previously at genentech
and the entire
group at genentech for collaborating
with us on the sandpiper clinical trial
analysis and finally to the many
patients all over the world who have
obtained biopsies
with us and have enrolled on pip kinase
inhibitor trials over the years
this is a list of my funding sources and
at this time
i would be happy to take any questions
thank you very much